Va, són les 9 de la nit, tinc una vaca aquí.
Bueno, si et pires millor, no? Jo crec.
Vinga, va. Fora.
De punt la vull cabrejar molt, que... Vale.
Sembla que s'ha donat a la meva presència
i prefereix anar-se'n a una altra banda. 9 de la nit, eh?
Encara hi ha molta nit per endavant. Vale.
Va, hi ha una altra, veig. No es veu aquí el mòbil, però hi ha una altra.
Bueno, digue-li, digue-li a l'altre que no s'apropi, tampoc, eh?
Vinga, bona nit.
Passa, ja tinc la bossa penjada, la veieu? Florescent.
A les vaques els agrada tot el que fa voler menjar.
La volta al món a peu, dia 273.
A les 12 van tornar les vaques.
Van ficar bastant a prop i aquesta vegada...
no les vaig poder allunyar.
Vaig fer, eh, eh, eh, però, bueno, es van quedar a prop i ja està.
No m'han molestat més en tota la nit, per tant, dono per satisfet.
De fet, he dormit tan bé que m'he llevat a les 7.
Compara amb ahir, amb el tema del gai,
que a les 5 i pico, 6 ja estava caminant,
i avui són les 8 i 12 i encara...
encara no he recollit. És la teoria del pèndol, no?
No ho sé, no sé si és la teoria del pèndol, però jo li dic així,
que un dia faig molt i el dia segon he estat cansat, estic cansat i faig poc.
Va així. Va així bastant, bastant, bastant.
Ara veig un pagès allà al fons, que, bueno, l'he saludat abans.
Ei, hola.
He agafat el menjar, les vaques no se l'havien menjat.
Doncs, bueno, avui tocarà...
bastanta més calor, suposo, res.
Som-hi.
Són les 9, encara es va prou bé.
Veig aquí com una fàbrica de marbre.
No, bueno, una cantera de marbre, més aviat.
Sí, sí, sí. Bueno, una cosa que fa dies que vull dir,
però que sempre me n'oblido.
A veure, la bandera. No porto la bandera. Per què?
Bueno, perquè, en canvi de regió, estem al Pamir,
a la regió de Gormisbonistan, es diu, o alguna cosa així.
Ja està. Ara ja, doncs, traient la bandera i ja està.
Bueno, la guardo? No, no la guardo, no la guardo, ja no la tinc.
Bueno, per l'aerografia del terreny,
sembla que, com a mínim aquest matí, tindrem bastanta solana.
Aquí, a un restaurant, malauradament, a aquesta hora, doncs, no pararia de dinar.
I el següent, doncs, hauré de mirar quan està, però potser avui no...
potser avui no en tenim. Coses de la vida.
Mira quina bogeria de talús que n'ha excavat aquí, eh?
Això deu tenir, què? Més de 50 metres d'alt, eh? És enorme, eh?
Tajikistan serà un país...
que, bueno, podrem considerar que no està molt desenvolupat, el que sigui,
però si hi ha una cosa que, de veritat, ens passa la mà per la cara és amb el tema de cotxes elèctrics, eh?
Perquè hi ha moltíssims cotxes elèctrics. A Dushanbe, sobretot, és una passada.
No sé si són la majoria, potser no, però n'hi ha molts, tots els taxis són elèctrics.
I aquí estem al Pamir, estem a un lloc deixat de la Mare de Déu, gairebé,
i hi ha una estació de càrrega de veïns elèctrics. Sí, sí, sí, sí.
Suposo que volen reduir la dependència del petroli. No ho sé.
També m'han preguntat l'altre dia com valia la gasolina.
Doncs mira, no m'he trobat cap gasolinera aquests últims dies que posi els preus.
Sé que aquí al Pamir és més car que a Dushanbe. A Dushanbe sí que vaig a veure els preus, però ara no me'n recordo, no me'n recordo.
I una altra cosa que és que, bueno, al final ja porto dies caminant per aquí i m'acostumo, eh? Però el paisatge...
El paisatge és únic, eh?
Jo crec que per veure muntanyes així, a pocs llocs del món les trobaràs.
En refereixo amb aquesta paleta de colors tan sec.
Les muntanyes a la vegada són tan, tan altes. Veus neu en algunes d'aquestes aquí de darrere.
És molt, molt guapo, eh?
Sempre preferiré les muntanyes tipus Alps, no?, o Pirineus que són més verdes, però això també mola.
Doncs ara aquí darrere hi havia un check point i hi havia un tio allà enviant documents, però a mi m'han dit, passa, passa.
He de tenir cara de bona persona.
Bueno, aquí tenim un gran riu. Com veieu ara aquesta zona de la frontera i tal, doncs és bastant diferent.
Però la idea és anar cap allà i tornar una mica al paisatge d'aquests últims dies, que és la vall més angosta, la carretera Sitxonguilla, Afganistan allà super al prop i tal.
La carretera Sitxonguilla, Afganistan allà super al prop i tal.
Vinga, hi ha un restaurant que surt al mapa, però només té revius des de fa... l'última és de fa dos anys. Per tant, saps, no és molt de fi. A veure què hi ha.
Ara hi ha al darrere, hi ha el segon pont que he vist de frontera entre Afganistan i Tajikistan.
No he volgut gravar massa descredament perquè, bé, no vull que em vegin, però molt poca presència militar.
No, amb molt control i tal, simplement. Tampoc veig ningú creuant. Normalitat.
Bueno, ara de cop i volta, de cop i volta hi ha bastant trànsit. Això és bo. Això vol dir que si hi ha trànsit, hi ha conductors que necessiten menjar i alguna cosa trobarem, no? No sé.
Bueno, ara de cop i volta hi ha bastant trànsit. Això és bo. Això vol dir que si hi ha trànsit, hi ha conductors que necessiten menjar i alguna cosa trobarem.
Les 12 i mitja. La calor és brutal.
Com més estreta és la vall, menys bufa el vent i llavors s'acumula la calor aquí baix i no... La calor és brutal, eh?
Encara dos quilòmetres fins al poble que no sé si hi haurà res.
Però trec el mòbil per dir que acabo de veure la primera col·laboració entre els dos països, entre Tajikistan i Afganistan, que és aquesta línia elèctrica.
Aquesta línia elèctrica d'alta tensió... Tenim torres a Tajikistan i va passant la torre fins a...
Bueno, Afganistan-Tajikistan va creuant el riu. Depèn del que comenta la biografia.
Bueno, tu, està molt bé, està molt bé. Que col·laborin i no...
Saps què seria més interessant, també? Que no ho he vist en cap altre lloc d'aquí.
Que les antenes telefòniques estiguessin a l'altra banda del país.
És a dir...
Hi ha molta més cobertura.
Si l'antena de 4G de Tajikistan està al costat afganès, perquè abarca més part tajika,
i al revés, que l'antena de 4G, el que tingui en Afganistan, estigui a la part tajiga, doncs donaria millor cobertura.
Però això no... Ja fins a tant no arriben.
La una.
Ja he arribat al poble aquest, veig dos camions...
Bueno, mira, no sé si hi haurà restaurant, però...
Només que hi hagi un supermercat per beure aigua freda...
Ja em conformo, eh?
Oh, sí que hi havia restaurant, sí. Sí, sí. I tenien... adivineu què?
Plouf. Plouf.
Ara estic aquí... no sé...
Fem una mica l'ombra en aquesta espècie de prat.
I volia gravar el vídeo quan aquesta màquina parés el motor, perquè se sentís millor,
però fa 5-10 minuts que està amb el motor encès i no l'apaga.
Poques ganes de caminar avui, eh? Són les dues i pico i porto ni 20 km.
Actualització a les 4 de la tarda,
esperant que el sol se'n vagi darrere de les muntanyes una mica,
per no anar tan asfixiat, perquè és bastant horrible.
Jo no sé per què, però hi ha determinades hores del dia
que passen més camions i més cotxes que altres.
Ara fa mitja hora que potser no veig cap cotxe.
O 15 minuts, no ho sé.
I de cop i volta, quan passen, comencen a passar tots a la vegada.
Jo crec que els camions deuen anar en convois, no? Deuen anar tots junts.
I els cotxes van darrere... no ho sé. No ho sé, no ho sé, no ho sé.
Ho desconec, però sol ser per allà...
Ui, què és això? Un control? Què és això?
Veig... Sol ser per allà a les 5-6 que comencen a passar bastant a saco.
Allà hi ha un pont i veig gent amb xalecos fluorescents.
No els gravaré, eh? Perquè potser són poles.
Ah, no, deuen ser treballadors que estan construint el pont.
Sí, sí, perquè veig que hi ha un pont antic i estan fent un pont nou.
Vale.
Actualització a les 5 de la tarda.
Molt millor ara sense el sol.
Tinc 4 mil·lilitres darrere, no sé si encara hi són, no vull girar-me.
Simplement han agafat un cotxe, han aparcat i han començat a caminar,
separats per 100 o 200 metres cadascun d'ells.
I, bueno, doncs jo vaig una mica més ràpid.
Ja els he passat.
Bueno, el baixatge és brutal, eh?
Bueno, és el consol que em queda perquè no tinc internet
i no tinc ningú amb qui parlar.
Crec que en aquesta banda del país deuen estar més acostumats a la gent, no?
Perquè aquí diuen passar turistes, ciclistes, el que sigui.
I, bueno, són simpàtics, són tàgics, són hospitalaris, tot el que vulguis,
però no emparen tant de
ostres, tu, tal, només en la típica hordes de nens, no.
També la cultura potser és diferent, no ho sé.
Bueno, tot.
30 quilòmetres, a veure si puc fer 10 més.
Una mica optimista, potser, però 7, 8, potser sí.
Actualització a les 6 de la tarda.
Ara, ara, us ho he dit, eh?
De 5 a 6 començava el trànsit.
I sí, sí, com veieu la carretera ha canviat bastant.
Seguirà estant asfaltada en alguns trams,
però ja no és de dos carrils allò amples, sinó que és d'un carril i té forats i tal.
Bueno, m'ha passat una cosa que no m'havia passat mai encara,
la volta amb una peu,
que és que han començat a venir camions de cara, no?
I un d'ells m'ha donat un pa.
M'havien donat vehicles, menjar.
Però és que no és només això, és que un d'ells m'ha donat un pa.
Després el següent, no sé si és perquè ho ha vist o què,
m'ha llançat una pova.
I un de més tard m'ha fet així, com dient,
vas a peu?
I jo, sí, sí.
I m'ha donat una ampolla de te.
Xinès.
Marca xinesa.
Comprat a la Xina, això és a la Xina, sí, sí, sí.
I de fet el que portava el camió no sé si era xinès, potser.
No ho sé, com els tejics també tenen una mica els ulls, una mica així.
Bueno.
35 quilòmetres ja.
Bastant bé. Encara caminaré uns 3 més o així.
Bueno, ara estic passant per un tram que veieu que hi ha bastantes cases,
i estan construint cases noves, i hi ha arbres a banda i a banda del camí.
Però hi ha un problema, que és que, clar,
cada cop que passa un vehicle o un camió d'aquests,
fuà, aixeca una de pols,
els haurien d'asfaltar urgentment aquesta pista,
perquè, fuà, és que tot s'omple de pols, eh?
Bueno, doncs, tenint en compte que ja
es va apropant l'hora de dormir,
a la que surti d'aquest poble que hi ha casa, casa, casa, casa,
amb una mica de sort segueix la zona plana
i puc posar la tenda a alguna banda.
L'hora dels campions, tu. Han passat 10 seguits. Horrible.
Bueno, què posa aquí?
Rush Russian Cross Border Energy Project,
lo que us he dit abans.
Les torres aquestes d'energia, cross border,
i això està finançat per Alemanya,
per Noruega,
i la bandera de Tajikistan i la bandera d'Afganistan.
Veig que la bandera de Tajikistan està tetchada.
Bueno, l'escut.
No ho sé. No parlarem d'aquest tema.
D'acord, aquí, a la torre aquesta d'alta tensió,
hi ha una zona plana i al costat dels arbres
sembla que també.
Per tant, doncs, crec que em posaré per aquí.
Uh! Sortia d'aigua.
Bueno, vaig bastant carregat d'aigua,
però, ostres, a més sembla neta.
Bastant transparent, sí.
Havia agafat una que era una mica tèrbola.
Ostres, espera, espera.
Això és uralita, eh?
Crec que això és uralita.
L'aigua baixa per un conducte d'uralita.
Doncs mira, crec que millor que no.
Millor no.
Tenim a estar literalment al costat de la carretera,
però, bueno, com hi ha alguns arbres,
tampoc està lluny d'un lloc militar que està cap allà,
però no en veuen des d'allà.
L'herba està un pèl alta, però, bueno, tampoc,
tampoc massa, eh?
Sí, sí, sí, jo crec que
està bastant decent el lloc.
Ei, mira, no, és un noi.
Malament.
Malament. Si en ve un, ja en pot venir tot el poble, ara.
El que pateixo és si està massa humit, això.
A veure.
No, no.
Per aquí, per allà, potser allà.
Ho veig una mica més sec.
El que veig és que està literalment al costat de la carretera, eh, ja.
Aquí potser millor.
Vale, planto.
Segueix la camionada, em veieu bé.
I també passen nens amb bicicleta i tal, el salut.
Avui 37,7 quilòmetres, 500 metres de desneig positiu.
10 quilòmetres menys que ahir.
És el que té començar a caminar dues hores més tard.
Bueno, tres refresc, cap te i de diners m'he gastat 12 euros.
Sí, sí, sí.
Bueno, ha sigut un dia més calorós que ahir, però menys polsagós.
No, va, és un dia més.
Un dia més a la meva ruta cap a la Xina.
Moments alts i baixos.
Ostres, tu olors als camions, és brutal. Es veuen, no?, des de la càmera.
Mira, aquest porta cotxes.
He de dir que hi ha una curiositat, que és que estic veient molts cotxes sense matrícula,
d'aquests blancs xinesos elèctrics, amb gent conduint-los.
No sé si és que, directament, en comptes per estalviar-se el tràiler,
els condueixen des de la Xina fins a Dushanbe per vendre'ls i així s'estalvien el tràiler,
o la gent els condueix sense matrícula.
No ho entenc, no ho entenc.
Val, com hi ha bastant de trànsit, doncs no esperaré que es faci fosc per passar-me una aigua,
avui estic bastant suat.
I fa bastant de calor.
Avui, com que estic bastant baix, no fa fred.
Res, bona nit.